des flammes de plusieurs mètres d'eau
dessus du marché couvert de maurepas ces
images datent d'il ya un an tout juste
dans la nuit du 31 juillet au 1er août
le site de 1900 mètres carrés qu'il
était de 1993 s'est embrasée il était de
très bonne qualité mais à croire que
l'incendié qui s'y est développée enfin
compte dans un local où on entreposait
des poubelles a été plus important que
cette ossature après un incendie le
marché a connu deux déplacements à
premier sur un petit parking à proximité
une structure provisoire de 800 m²
ensuite été mise en place à côté de
l'ancienne halle en novembre 2019
on y retrouve aujourd'hui 25 abonnés le
but est de retourner là bas pourquoi
parce qu'on a une très grosse perte de
volant les voleurs je vous est fixé les
gens qui viennent de passage et comme on
a empiété sur leur partie alors
d'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de volants
que son parti et qu'on retournera dans
la nouvelle halle tout ce parti-là
redeviendra accès au volant et aussi aux
brocantes et à un bien-être desmaures
patients pour un éventuel retour dans
l'ancienne halle des concertations
étaient menées sur le futur marché de
maurepas depuis plusieurs mois avec les
habitants les commerçants et les élus de
la commune
trois grands axes ont été définis
c'était qu'est ce qu'on voulait
maintenant pour maurepas est-ce que
c'était une halle ouvertes fermées ou
semi ouverte
ensuite le dimensionnement et ensuite
l'emplacement le diagnostic de cette
consultation sera dévoilé en fin d'année
par la municipalité